[Musique]
réservé aux initiés
ici à rennes le château nous nous
trouvons au coeur du mystère
ce minuscule hameau perché au sommet
d'une montagne dans les contreforts des
pyrénées jouer de l'un des panoramas les
plus éblouissants qu'on puisse imaginer
pourtant rares sont les visiteurs qui
viennent pour la vue ici ce qui attire
c'est lors le trésor le mystère
avant de clore notre enquête on peut se
demander si aveuglé par la beauté du
paysage nous ne sommes pas passés à côté
de la vérité pure et simple de l'endroit
car saunière et son village sont en
effet liés à cette obscure liste
d'hommes célèbres
ici dans le jardin de son église se
trouve le calvaire qu'il fit dressé
portant cette phrase énigmatique le
christ défend à au mps
l'ordre ancien et mystique ps
avons nous vraiment découvert une
société secrète
celle du prieuré de sion un savoir at il
pu se communiquer au fil des siècles
jusqu'à notre époque et être transmis un
homme tel que jean cocteau est ce
possible
le prieuré sa tribu lui même cet autre
titre ordre de la rose-croix veritas
durant la seconde guerre mondiale
l'église de notre dame de france à
londres fut bombardée
lorsqu'on l'a reconstruisit de célèbres
artistes français furent invités à la re
décorer
cocteau ip ni une fresque
cependant la crucifixion de cocteau et
mystérieuse on y voit que les pieds du
christ
qui plus est il a pas en bas de la croix
le symbole de la rose-croix veritas
mais sept oeuvres de cocteau dissimule
autre chose
ce visage est un autoportrait les lances
des soldats dessine une forme
géométrique autour de lui
quel en est le centre
cocteau a répété le tour de passe-passe
de poussins toutes les lignes parts du
visage de cocteau tout comme le
pentagone de poussins avaient pour
centre le front de la bergère
cette fois encore apparaît le même
leitmotiv l'étoile à cinq branches
pourquoi cette forme géométrique
revient-elle sans cesse
quel que soit lundi ce que nous
découvrons tout nous ramène aux pente
hac le mystique à l'étoile symbole de
vénus et de marie madeleine la sainte
patronne de rennes le château
peut-être cette société secrète qui
prétend avoir eu léonard de vinci newton
hugo et cocteau pour grands maîtres
peut-être cette organisation mystérieuse
détient tel un secret
la seule liste que nous ayons de ces
grands maîtres s'arrête à cocteau qui
mourut en 1963
un homme pierre plantard de sinclair dit
avoir été comme cocteau grand maître du
prieuré de sion un homme charmant
courtois poli ou cultivées et surtout
discret
en 1979 quand je l'interrogé au sujet du
prieuré de sion il m'a dit nous avons
soutenu sion est sûre nous allons
nous qui est ce nous nous je parle de la
lignée mérovingienne car notre ligne est
issu de dagoberto
le prieuré de sion est une organisation
qui se consacre au soutien et à la
protection des mérovingiens
mais pour autant qu'en dix l'histoire la
dynastie mérovingienne des rois français
a réellement pris fin avec saint
dagobert
dagobert 2 nous revoici donc au début de
notre longue chaîne indique le parchemin
de saunière stipulé ce trésor est à sion
et à dagobert 2
les mérovingiens et le prieuré de sion
saunière découvrit dans son église ce
bas-relief censé représenter un
chevalier portant secours au jeune fils
de dagobert qui selon la légende fonda
par la suite une famille ici à rennes le
château
monsieur planta grand maître du prieuré
de sion prétend être un descendant dit
l'acte de ce prince qui nous de vin
paroisse il soutient que le sang royal
des mérovingiens coule dans ses veines
mais pourquoi une organisation devrait
elle se perpétue et clandestinement un
millénaire durant pour protéger une
ancienne lignée serait ce pour atteindre
son objectif premier à savoir que cette
lignée royale accède à l'héritage
auxquelles elle a droit cette idée
semble absurde chimérique aussi
fantasque que futile et pourtant si le
prieuré de sion et bien une véritable
organisation
beaucoup de grands hommes se sont au fil
des siècles consacré à cet objectif ou à
quelque chose de plus vaste dont ce but
faisait partie
un savoir secret sur lequel vient se
greffer l'énigme d'un trésor
les histoires de trésors constitue une
admirable divertissement pour notre
culture moderne si axée sur l'argent
mais nous ne devons pas oublier certains
éléments de ce récit des choses qui
aujourd'hui semble sans importance les
croyances hérétiques la magie la
sorcellerie tenait une grande place dans
l'esprit de nos ancêtres
aussi grande que celle occupée par le
profit dans l'esprit du xxème siècle
pour comprendre le prieuré de sion nous
devons oublier la vision contemporaine
sceptiques et scientifiques que nous
avons du monde et essayer d'appréhender
l'univers tel que le voyez nos ancêtres
après tout le prieuré de sion n'est pas
l'unique groupe d'initiés connu le passé
en fait les formes géométriques
récurrentes évoque étrangement les
écoles l'initiation de l'antiquité comme
celle de pythagore qui se développèrent
à partir du 6e siècle avant jésus-christ
pour leurs disciples l'étoile à cinq
branches représente l éternité la vie et
la santé
quand j'ai parlé à monsieur planta des
connexions géométrique de notre récit je
lui ai demandé cette géométrie et
pentagone a mené par saad il a rétorqué
le pentagone pythagoriciens ce lui même
utilisé par cocteau dans son étrange
peinture rosicrucienne
employés par poussin dans sa
représentation du paysage de rennes le
château
est dissimulée dans le parchemin que
saunière découvrit dans son église
dédiée à marie madeleine la sainte
acquis les initiés du moyen-âge
attribuer le même symbole
cette même sainte qui selon la légende
ramena le saint graal en france le saint
graal cet objet mystérieux constitue un
des maillons de notre chaîne d' indice
un maillon relié à plus d'un autre
anneau de la chaîne
le saint graal faisait partie du ton du
trésor des cathares or les templiers
étaient appelés gardiens du saint graal
ou encore familles du graal dans les
récits médiévaux ayant trait au saint
graal
que peut bien signifier tout cela
qu'est ce que le saint graal
on considère en général qu'il s'agit
d'une coupe ou d'un calice la coupe que
jésus et ses disciples utilisèrent lors
de la scène où celle dans laquelle le
sang du christ fut recueilli lors de sa
crucifixion
un réceptacle du sang sacré de jésus
ramener en france par marie madeleine
le saint graal
dans les premières versions de
l'histoire du graal et celles ci ont des
liens avec les templiers il était
référence à ce mystérieux objet non sous
le nom de saint graal mais sous celui de
san graal
si nous en sommes venus à penser qu'il
s'agissait d'une coupe ou d'un calice
c'est parce qu'il existe un terme celte
dont la sonorité est très proche du mot
graal qui signifie coupe ou calice
d'où l'expression san graal le 5 à l'iss
toutefois ses liens avec le sang du
christ sont si étroits qui convient de
se demander si le sann graal cette chose
étrange ne serait pas plutôt le sens
râle
non non pas le saint graal mais le sang
royal une éventualité surprenante se
présente soudain nous
quand marie madeleine arriva en france
avec le saint graal peut-être n'était-ce
pas une coupe qu'elle portait mais le
sang royal la lignée royale de jésus
serait ce la raison pour laquelle les
templiers et est décrit comme étant les
gardiens du cral et la famille du graal
cette famille auraient-elles été
constitué par les descendants de jésus
je sais que cette idée qui frôle le
blasphème en choquera plus d'un et
pourtant si certains de nos ancêtres il
y avait cru
sont jezzy
le prieuré de sion prétend être à
l'origine des chevaliers du temple
et selon monsieur planta le prieuré
soutenait et protéger la lignée
celle des mérovingiens de saint dagobert
cela expliquerait-il pourquoi les
mérovingiens été reconnu roy par
l'église du fait du droit du sang
non grâce à l'onction de l'église mais
par le droit divin
soudain une image choquante et
hérétiques prend forme
à partir des nombreux fragments de ce
mystère on peut émettre une hypothèse
extraordinaire
jésus était de la maison royale et de la
lignée de david
les rois mages voyait en lui celui qui
est né roi des juifs il mourut avec le
même titre inscrit sur sa croix et
nrj les housses nazarene irex ou des
roms jésus de nazareth croix des juifs
il fut condamné pour crime contre l'état
romain
et la crucifixion et est le châtiment
réservé à de tels crimes
était-il en fait un roi essayant de
regagner son trône
et c'est après la crucifixion que
marie-madeleine arrivant en france avec
le réceptacle contenant le sang du
christ
s'agissait-il de sa descendance du sang
des rois d'israël
nous devons maintenant nous demander si
marie madeleine elle même n'était pas
tout simplement le réceptacle du sang du
christ
en d'autres termes ses entrailles le
graal aurait-elle renfermé la
progéniture du christ
marie-madeleine aurait-elle été la fan
de jésus
il faut à nouveau rappeler que si cette
idée peut nous sembler odieuse elle
faisait peut-être partie des croyances
de certains de nos ancêtres
parmi les premières formes du
christianisme certaines comme
l'arianisme considéré jésus comme un
homme non comme un dieu
et les wisigothe à kissenda gaubert
était apparenté par les liens du mariage
étaient des aryens
ses descendants et le prieuré de sion
qui les soutient pourrait bien avoir
entretenu ses croyances même
lorsqu'elles étaient si violemment
combattue par l'église romaine
l'idée de jésus en tant qu'homme et père
ne leur aurais peut-être pas semblé très
choquant contrairement à nous qui sommes
si profondément influencé par la foi
dans laquelle nous avons été élevés
mais même si c'était le cas pourquoi la
famille de jésus à supposer qu'elle ait
existé aurait-elle fui en france aussi
étrange que cela puisse paraître c'est
là un asile évident
autrefois il existait ici une communauté
juive solidement établie aujourd'hui
oublié une communauté autonome avec sa
propre maison royale
si le sang royal celui de la maison de
david a effectivement fui en france cela
éclaircirait bien des aspects de
l'histoire obscur de cette région
cela expliquerait pourquoi l'église
reconnaissait les mérovingiens comme roi
de par leur sens pourquoi l'aurait-elle
fait si elle n'avait pas cru qu'il
s'agissait d'une ligne est sacré de la
dynastie mérovingienne ayant en fait
survécu après le meurtre de saint
dagobert
une ligne est protégé par les gardiens
du saint graal et la famille du graal
c'est à dire les chevaliers du temple
voilà une hypothèse bien séduisante une
hypothèse qui nous ramène vers le
premier indice de notre mystère ce
trésor est à dagobert et à sion
on se rend bien compte qu'une idée si
hérétiques à supposer que certains aient
cru dans le passé n'aurait pu être
exprimé à haute voix sans danger elle
aurait donc été conservée comme un
savoir secret solis sacerdoti bus
réservé aux initiés
mais à la fin du xxème siècle quelle
conclusion pouvons nous tirer de tout ça
l'idée choquant d'une descendance de
jésus n'est qu'une hypothèse
non un fait établi
la croyance et la foi ne doivent pas
être affectés par des hypothèses
historique je crois n'est pas la même
chose que je sais peu importe que nous
même soyons prêts à accepter ou rejeter
cette idée ce qui compte c'est que
quelqu'un dans le passé peut-être le
prieuré de sion et pu y croire
quelle certitude avons-nous donc pour le
savoir nous devons éliminer tout
mystification qu'elle est en fait la
source de ce mystère
l'histoire de bérenger saunière fut pour
la première fois porté à l'attention du
public au début des années 1960
mais cette histoire n'est fondée que sur
des ouï-dire elle fut présentée comme la
quête d'un trésor perdu
une fois révélée elle déclencha une
vague de chasse au trésor dans la région
dès les premiers jours de mai recherche
à la fin des années 60 je me suis aperçu
qu'on pensait automatiquement que moi
aussi je cherchais cet or
des chasseurs de trésors sans scrupules
m'observait constamment à mon insu et si
je m'intéresse est trop à une chose ou
un endroit particulier il faisait vite
l'objet d'attentions fâcheuses
ainsi la tombe de la dame blanche fort
était une pierre rectangulaire intacte
lorsque je les filme et pour la première
fois en 1971
quelques jours plus tard quelqu'un
l'avait brisée en essayant de la
soulever aujourd'hui certains de ces
fragments au même disparu
quant à la tombe représenté par poussin
elle resta intacte et ignorer jusqu'au
jour où je m'y intéresser en 1971 le
jour même on essaya pour la première
fois de la forcer à présent hélas il
n'en reste rien
cependant avant même que j'apparais sur
la scène c'est abominable chasseur de
trésor faisait déjà des ravages
le village avait été contraint de
rédiger un arrêté municipal qui
interdisait les fouilles à ces gens sans
scrupules fouilles interdite oui la
cupidité chez certains une force
impérieuse détestable et l'histoire de
saunière attiré plus d'un membre de
cette odieuse confrérie
mais cette histoire nous a conduits dans
de lointains recoins du passé et vers
l'idée séduisante d'un éventuel mariage
entre jésus et marie madeleine
comme je m'y attendais l'ours punch de
publier pour la première fois cette
hypothèse en 1982 dans mon livre le sens
a créé le saint graal elle attira
l'attention du monde entier
je le souligne anne ouvrait ce n'est
rien d'autre qu'une idée une hypothèse
non elle n'est pas prouvée
croire à de telles choses comme en fait
à n'importe quel système de croyance est
essentiellement une affaire d'opinion on
peut choisir de croire au diable ou
parte
on peut choisir de croire que
marie-madeleine a été la femme de jésus
ou pas on peut choisir de croire que la
terre est plate ou pas
mais dans ce dernier cas nous quittons
le domaine de la croyance pour entrer
dans le monde des fai démontrable
si on ne peut pas prouver que dieu
existe
on peut en revanche démontré que la
terre est ronde par conséquent bien
qu'on ne puisse pas prouvé que le prêtre
est découvert un trésor que le prieuré
de sion existe ou encore que jésus est
une descendance on peut certainement
démontrer pourquoi ce village est au
coeur d'un tel mystère
cette enquête va maintenant apporter la
preuve que rennes le château constitue
elle même ce ter
[Musique]
nous sommes sur le point de faire une
découverte étonnante d'ouvrir une
fenêtre totalement nouvelles sur le
passé
nos prochains pas nous guideront vers
une chose merveilleuse que nos ancêtres
nous ont laissés ici ainsi que sur l'île
lointaine de bornholm
il s'agit d'un secret transmis de siècle
en siècle
transmis et garder telle une information
confidentielle secrète solis sacerdoti
bus réservé aux initiés
[Musique]
un trésor des secrets et mystères
nous parcourons un long chemin tortueux
à la recherche d'un prêtre français
morts et de son présumé trésor
à
chaque étape nous nous sommes trouvés
confrontés aux brumes enveloppant de la
confusion à de fausses pistes à l'obscur
indices tout ceci visant à nous
détourner d'une chose qui semble
désespérément proche mais qui reste
pourtant hors d'atteinte un savoir
secret
solis sacerdoti booth réservé aux
initiés
rennes le château est le village où le
mystère n'a qu' c'est dans l'église
dédiée à marie madeleine que saunière
découvrit les parchemin du prieuré de
sion dans lesquels étaient dissimulés un
pan tacle
saunière acheta par ailleurs une
reproduction du tableau de poussin sur
lequel figure la tombe située près de
rennes le château
on retrouve également le pentacle dans
cette toile la fresque de cocteau grand
maître présumé du prieuré de sion
renferme elle aussi la même géométrie
marie madeleine à qui l'église est dédié
constitue le médium de la révélation
secrète elle est représentée dans le
ciel par le paon tacle de vénus cette
figure géométrique l'étoile à cinq
branches étroitement liée à la magie et
aux sciences occultes
mais cette chaîne d' indices nous a
conduit bien loin de ce village une
chaîne dont jérusalem constitue un autre
maillon
il en va de même pour la lointaine île
de bornes heaulme situé dans la mer
baltique les églises ronde de bornes
heaulme date des croisades
elle révèle l influence des chevaliers
du temple ses célèbres moines guerriers
du moyen-âge
les templiers sont eux-mêmes enveloppée
de mystère
cette étrange documents découverts à la
bibliothèque nationale de paris dresse
la liste des premiers grand maître de
l'ordre et fait allusion à des liens
avec une autre organisation mystérieuse
le prieuré de sion
le prieuré semble renfermer le savoir
secret qui est à l'origine de notre
mystère
[Musique]
explorez l'invisible
aujourd'hui on peut se demander pourquoi
un quelconque savoir devraient rester
secrets mais posséder le savoir c'est
détenir le pouvoir et pas simplement
dans un sens mystique est magique comme
cela a pu être le cas pour nos ancêtres
aujourd'hui encore cela représente un
danger après tout la bombe atomique
était le fruit d'un savoir secret qui a
permis de gagner la seconde guerre
mondiale certaines formes de savoirs
secrets ont été transmises de génération
en génération à travers des
compagnonnages et des sociétés secrètes
or nous avons déjà rencontré une telle
société secrète le prieuré de sion qui
prétend être à l'origine de l'ordre du
temple mais quel secret d'état est il
exactement
nous nous sommes assignés la tâche de
trouver de véritables preuves des
éléments qui ne saurait être réfuté tout
nous à présent vers les vestiges des
templiers et procédant de façon aussi
simple que possible
nous savons qu'à côté de rennes le
château se trouvent deux forteresses
ayant des liens avec les templiers
chacune est perché en haut d'une
montagne naturel
et bien sûr rennes le château se trouve
elle aussi au sommet d'une montagne
visibles les unes des autres ces
montagnes forme d'un triangle fascinant
la distance séparant bézu de rennes le
château est la même que celle existant
entre bézu et blanches fort
les angles de ces sommes mais sont
significatifs 36° 72 degrés est à
nouveau 72° un triangle parfaitement
isocèle
or en associant cinq triangle comme
celui ci on obtient un pentagone ce qui
nous ramène à notre unique certitude un
triangle que forment les cimes de trois
montagnes
mais qu'en est il des deux autres
sommets de l'étoile
chose étonnante il correspond aussi aux
signes de montagne naturel cinq
montagnes disposés de façon parfaitement
symétrique un pan tacle géant et
naturelles dont la géométrie parfaite
semble presque délibéré les chances de
trouver cinq montagnes ainsi disposer
sont tout comme les mouvements de vénus
astronomiquement rare
sur la terre comme au ciel
dès l'instant où ils ont pris conscience
pour la première fois de cette
disposition pentagone al parfaite et
nous ne savons pas encore à caen cela
remonte dès cet instant donc cet endroit
semble avoir été considéré comme un lieu
sacré et saint
leu saint des saints
cette perfection quasi divine semble
avoir incité les détenteurs du savoir
secret c'est à dire le clergé ou encore
les initier à enfermer leurs lieux
saints dans un temple invisible dont la
structure même s'imposer 2 par la
disposition des montagnes
cette forme et est si extraordinaire
qu'elle inspirait crainte et respect aux
anciens qui voyaient en elle la
représentation de l'harmonie du cosmos
divin les droites qui constituent les
branches du paon tacle se croisent dans
une proportion harmonieuse qui
correspond à ce que l'on appelle le
nombre d'or
regardez sur la carte cette étoile
étonnante
les montagnes constituent trois de ses
sommets chacun était une distance fixe
de son angle opposé et chose curieuse
c'est la même distance qui sépare les
églises de rennes le château et de
rennes les bains
ceci bien sûr pourrait n'être qu'une
simple coïncidence mais regardez
on retrouve la même distance entre les
églises de rennes le château et de
campagne sur aude
peut-être n'est-ce encore qu'une
coïncidence
mais est-ce à nouveau une coïncidence si
la même distance sépare également les
églises de luc sur aude et de serre
d'arqués de pérols d'arc et de terol
de terol et de saint-salvayre d'antugnac
et de roquetaillade de bouriège et de
crewe de la vallée de saint-just
et l'église d'espéraza de celle de
coustaussa de granès de saint ferriol et
de laisser aux îles
ce n'est plus là une coïncidence mais
une autre force habile délibéré et
intelligente car aussi remarquable soit
elle la récurrence d'une même distance
entre plusieurs édifices n'est qu'un
aspect minimes de l'immense travail
entrepris ici
l'église du village d'espéraza est situé
à égale distance de quatre autres
églises
ces dernières sont placés sur la
circonférence d'un immense cercle dont
l'église d'espéraza et le centre mais il
ya encore quelque chose à ajouter par
rapport à leur disposition sur le cercle
club
ce segment représente la distance
séparant coustaussa de granès une
distance établi avec le plus grand soin
et voilà à nouveau notre pentagone
mystique et magique mais cette fois il
ne s'agit pas de montagne placé là par
les dieux mais d'église délibérément et
méticuleusement construite par l'homme
pour nous c'est d'autant plus
remarquable que nous découvrons le lien
existe entre ce prodige pyrénéens et
cette minuscule île de la mer baltique
bornholm est une petite île bien dessiné
les églises ne sont pas nombreuses mais
regardez
à partir de deux églises et d'une toute
petite île isolée aussi incroyable que
cela puisse paraître on peut tracer une
droite qui nous permettra d'observer la
même géométrie
nous sommes maintenant en présence
d'éléments subtil et complexe
afin que les choses soient bien claires
nous devons avancer pas à pas dans ce
passionnant mystère
je me trouve ici au centre de bornes
heaulme qui est également le point
culminant de l'île au fil des siècles
les arbres ont poussé tout un tour mais
autrefois quand la vue était dégagé
j'aurais constater que cet endroit se
trouvait dans l'alignement parfait de
deux églises situées au sommet des deux
collines clemens caire est rude ce faire
nous avons par ici l'église d'ipsca
et par là celle de knut
et toutes deux constituent les points
d'une droite qui passe également par les
si
de surcroît si on observe l'intersection
de ces droite passant par le sommet de
cette colline et par ces églises on
obtient à nouveau le nombre d'or
cette disposition géométrique est
véritablement remarquable ce point
central se trouve très exactement à
équidistance dips caire et de l'église
de poulx caire et chose encore plus
surprenante la distance entre poulx
caire et ips caire représente exactement
la moitié de celle séparant ips père de
knut scraire
ici se trouve l'une des églises les plus
intéressantes et les plus importantes de
ban d'rôle mme nous voici devant la
magnifique église rondot ce terreau
l'art qui rappelle tant le cap et
limites et yom des templiers
il existe à ban d'rôle quatre églises de
cette fois mais elles sont uniques non
seulement à ban d'rôle mais dans
l'ensemble du danemark nous commençons à
présent à comprendre à quel point c est
glissant particulière
l'église de sterela se trouve au coeur
de cette géométrie telle une araignée au
centre de sa toile
de l'autre côté de l'île allie l'art se
dresse une autre église ronde les
églises de sterela denis l'arrêt de
rüdiger se trouve sur la circonférence
d'un seul et même cercle
voici l'emplacement de l'église de vst
remarie
ce segment représente exactement un
quart de la longueur du rayon du cercle
ce qui prouve à nouveau la précision des
distances observées ici
l'église dolce kirk trouve sa place sur
une étoile à six branches
holtz kirk est une autre des
merveilleuses église ronde de bornes
rôle l'emplacement de cette église a
longtemps intrigué les historiens
on aurait pu s'attendre à ce qu'elle
soit érigée au sommet de la colline
alors pourquoi at elle été placée 150
mètres plus bas
à présent la question ne se pose plus la
disposition géométriques en a imposé
l'emplacement avec une précision
étonnante
nous verrons plus tard que ce même point
comporte d'autres implication
remarquable mais revenons-en à notre
géométrie
l'église dolce kirk a permis de définir
un hexagone une étoile à six branches
qui s'inscrit élégamment dans un cercle
parfait
transposons cette figure si
significative à rennes le château
souvenez-vous deux des églises partager
ce cercle en cinq parties donnant ainsi
naissance à un pentax mais deux autres
églises s'inscrivent aussi dans ce
cercle délimitant ainsi six segments
on obtient alors le mystique sceau de
salomon aussi reconnaissable que le pan
tacle du magicien empli d'un symbolisme
religieux
qu'en est il du saint des saints de
notre premier pentagone formé à partir
des montagnes
tout se tient à la perfection les points
sont placés de façon si précise que
cette droite se divise en deux segments
parfaitement égaux
lorsque je montais pour la première fois
dans la tour magdala de saunière il ya
de cela plus de 20 ans je n'imaginais
pas jusqu'où m'entraînerai ce qu'il me
semblait alors que le petit mystère d'un
prêtre de village et de son trésor
j'ai à présent découvert ce complexe
réseau de droite d'angle et de distance
minutieusement calculé qui relie les
édifices des nombreux villages qui ment
tout
un réseau invisible uniquement
perceptible des dieux et qu'eux seuls
connaissent les détenteurs du savoir
secret
réservé aux initiés
mais qu'elle pouvait bien être le sens
d'un tel labeur
il a dû falloir de nombreuses années
peut-être des siècles pour mener à bien
une telle entreprise mais dans quel but
pour l'instant nous ne pouvons
qu'émettre des hypothèses
à rennes-le-château il s'agissait
d'embellir le saint des saints mais à
born rôle mme une autre motivation
semble étrange
l'explication réside dans les quatre
églises ronde le remplacement semble
arbitraire mais il révèle en fait une
géométrie incroyablement sophistiqués
nous nous trouvons là confrontés aux
mystères antique du cercle et du carré
le cercle qui s'inscrit dans ce carré
englobe l'église de clemens caire dans
sa circonférence
et cette église permet de dessiner une
étoile à cette branche
une nouvelle figure destinée peut-être à
nous rappeler les planètes visible ou
les sept jours de la semaine
la droite qui part de clemens caire
située sur l'un des sommets de l'étoile
à cette branche est qui passe par
l'église d'europe nous entraîne jusqu'à
la minuscule île de christiane saut à 24
kilomètres de bornes rôle si l'on prend
comme rayon la distance séparant austère
l'art de christiane so on peut tracer un
cercle qui englobe la totalité de
banderoles à l'intérieur de ce cercle un
triangle équilatéral ayant pour sommer
christiane sow renferme un autre cercle
plus petit sur lequel se trouve l'église
lipsky recul et la distance séparant
ostergaard ips kirk est identique à
celle existant entre les deux églises
ronde dolce qui recueille et de nikkei
c'est comme si nous étions en présence
d'un professeur essayant de nous
apprendre à résoudre un problème
complexe
l'île de bornholm constitue peut être un
terrain d'essai solis sacerdoti booth
réservé aux initiés
quiconque a conçu cette merveille était
étonnamment doux et même en disposant
des techniques sophistiquées du 20e
siècle nous avons à faire un problème
délicat
imaginez donc à quel point il a dû être
difficile pour nos ancêtres non
seulement de concevoir de tels plans
mais ensuite de les réaliser à grande
échelle alors qu'il ne disposait pas à
l'époque pour autant qu'on sache de
telles techniques
il semble qu'ils nous aient laissé là
une merveille comparable aux splendeurs
de l'antiquité
nous avons à maintes reprises observés
les liens existants entre les principaux
endroits de notre investigation
notre triangle prend maintenant une
nouvelle signification
jérusalem est à la même distance de
rennes-le-château que deux bandes paul
qui plus est la droite principale
passant par christiane soe bornes rhône
mène directement à rennes le château
mais ce n'est pas tout les deux figures
emprunte la même unité de mesure 1000
unités exactement sépare le village de
l'île et les deux autres côté du
triangle mesure chacun demi unité
cela prouve un sens des mesures et de
l'arpentage qu'on ne soupçonnait
nullement chez nos ancêtres et pourtant
de par leur nature toutes ces relations
sont difficiles à saisir appréhendait
après tout elles sont invisibles
accessible seulement aux initiés
mais il existe une preuve tangible qui
nous aidera les appréhender
la construction même de l'église de
stellar nous révélera des secrets dont
nous n'avions pas idée jusqu'à présent
l'église est construite sur trois
niveaux il est intéressant de les
examiner de près à l'origine il n'y
avait pas de toit mais une rotonde
entouré d'un rempart
aujourd'hui le rempart a été rehaussée
afin de soutenir un toit conique
autrefois ces fenêtres données sur
l'extérieur
on peut remarquer à quel point ces
terres ont été soigneusement taillée les
plans montre bien la précision avec
laquelle ces ouvertures ont été placés
sur la rotonde et les angles ont été
minutieusement calculé
sur la rotonde intérieur le choix des
emplacements est encore plus intéressant
cette fenêtre et celle d'en face sont
parfaitement alignés et bien sûr avant
que les remparts ne soit élevé ses
fenêtres s'ouvraient sur l'extérieur
dans quelles intentions ses fenêtres
ont-elles été aligné avec tant de
précision
eh bien laissez moi vous montrer quelque
chose
mais ici la bougie est parfaitement
visible mais il suffit qu'on se déplace
légèrement d'un côté de l'autre pour que
la flamme disparaissent
d'un signal ou une torche brûlant ici
aurait été tout à fait visible mais
seulement s'il se trouvait dans un axe
bien précis déterminés par l'emplacement
des fenêtres
on entrevoit à présent la façon dont la
géométrie des livres a été élaboré
nous avons bien progressé dans notre
enquête sur le trésor du prêtre français
il est plus probable que ce trésor soit
en fait un secret plutôt qu'un simple
butin constitué d'or et de bijoux
mais les secrets le savoir mais nos
pouvoirs
ne connaîtront peut-être jamais
l'origine de la fortune de saunière
le diable nous entraîner dans bien des
recoins obscurs du passé
le comprenons maintenant que cette
histoire de trésor est basé sur des
incertitudes
seule la géométrie et les unités de
mesures constituent des preuves
tangibles
je sais très bien que toute cette
géométrie et très décourageante surtout
dans le cadre d'un bref film
documentaire
cependant ce que vous avez vu ce n'est
qu'une parcelle de cette enquête
tout la géométrie ou du moins les
figures que nous avons examinés sont
d'une élégance superbe étonnante et
complexe
je sais aussi qu'il s'agit d'une
découverte difficile
nombreux sont les experts dans les
domaines que nous avons abordé
l'histoire et l'archéologie par exemple
qui ont du mal à admettre que nos
lointains ancêtres auraient disposé d'un
savoir sophistiqué en avance sur son
temps
s'il y répugne c'est parce que de telles
hypothèses ont été émises dans le passé
par des penseurs plein de bonne volonté
attirés par les domaines les plus
contestables du mystique séisme
la différence cruciale avec
l'extraordinaire preuve géométriques que
nous avons découvert réside dans sa
cohérence et surtout dans son extrême
précision
les faits que vous avez observé la
géométrie l'emplacement des églises les
figures significatives sont démontrable
ils peuvent être vérifiée et prouvée
bien que nous n'ayons nullement atteint
le terme de notre enquête quels sont
pour l'instant les conclusions que nous
pouvons tirant
tout d'abord nos lointains aïeux
possédait à l'évidence des compétences
et un savoir bien plus important que ce
que nous aurions jamais pu imaginer
et grâce à ses compétences ils ont pu
modeler leur environnement de manière
étonnamment géométriques et
mathématiques mais pourquoi
nous ne devons pas oublier que notre
conception de l'univers diffère de la
leur
leurs motivations ne peuvent être
appréhendés selon les critères du 20e
ciel
selon moi il s'agissait pour eux
d'accomplir une oeuvre religieuse
il reconnaissait par l'ats l'existence
et la puissance de leurs dieux
afin de terminer sur une preuve
remarquable j'illustrerai mes propos par
un exemple clair et
chaque matin nous voyons le soleil se
lever sur un jour nouveau aux yeux de
nos ancêtres cette suprême source de
lumière et de vie était une
manifestation des mécanismes harmonieux
de l'univers de dieu
à bandol mme lemay graff le géométrique
est à son apogée
sauf erreur les initiés aurait même pu
se constituer la un calendrier
extrêmement précis si tel est le cas
cette fenêtre devrait mettre en évidence
le solstice d'été
comme on le voit les fenêtres
intérieures ont une forme bien précises
heureusement l'une d'entre elle permet
toujours d'avoir vue sur l'extérieur car
les dans l'alignement d'une ouverture
dans le second rempart et le 21 juin à
la saint-jean le jour du solstice d'été
nous pouvons à nouveau remarquer la
précision de ces alignements
aujourd'hui le 21 juin les premiers
rayons du soleil levant s'infiltreront
par cette ouverture
cela constituera la balise infaillible
du jour le plus long de l'année et
marquera le début de la lente descente
du soleil vers l'hiver
et là le soleil levant de ce 21 juin
nous offre un léger râpé reçus de cette
merveille qui a été au fil des siècles
mystérieusement oublié
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]